take us through these tweets what should
we care about it separate the wheat from
the chaff here well I'm struggling with
it in terms of the voter fraud this
seems to be about Donald Trump's ego and
the fact that he made the statement
which the New York Times has called I
lie that there were millions of people
who voted illegally and that he would
have won the election otherwise 137
million votes cast in the election in
2016 and about eight instances of voter
fraud found around the country from the
various states that are reported it's
important to remember that the majority
of states have Republican governors so
these are Republican states that in
theory would be on his side they're not
finding voter fraud so it's not clear
where he's going for this other than the
fact that he's been pressed on it and
people are calling him a liar and he
doesn't seem to like it he seems to want
to be able to prove its unfinished lie
is a very strong word what is that he
that was the word the New York Times
used on the front it is the word the New
York Times used but he has said that he
has seen in information that would
indicate there was fraud we can't say
that he's wrong about that now whether
information is credible or not as a
separate question Russians are they're
credible sources right right and that's
what we don't know nobody has been able
to find any credible sources Sean Spicer
suggested yesterday the President had
some so this is a lettuce know what you
know I'm gonna pal and Ruskin on the
spot you're in front of the Bloomberg
you're on the trading floor over at
deutsche bank and these kind of
headlights come across these kind of
tweets come out do you guys care not on
this one no you know there are some
tweets that we may be would care about
schwanz Allen you know if you hear
something on say Keystone I'm clearly
the markets responded I know where there
was news or not news but you kind of you
know you do respond i think some of the
auto ones the market has cared possibly
you know their sensitivities particular
as it relates to auto stocks and
individual stars but that's it you know
not really my world but a foreign
exchange market or maybe respond a
little bit to those but yeah but this is
the problem that Michael you know how
did you conduct analysis when you kind
of look at this and wonder is this just
theatre is this material does it matter
how do you do that a lot of it is
theatre but then he says he's going to
announce his Supreme Court nominees and
then that is something that's actionable
and
you know they consider business cases so
obviously for Alan and his people that's
important as well so half of its
important half of its theater at this
point